they think they think they're gonna do
it before this market frenzy runs out
well there are two sides of the story
obviously this has been a great run up
these brokerages in China have been
expanding they've been providing all the
different services including margin
trading of course but at the same time
are we reaching the end of this boom you
know this market shanghai composite
index has more than doubled in the last
eight months it is getting quite frothy
and the PE s are getting quite
overvalued but it wants to capitalize
obviously on the stock market boom and
raise funds to replenish capital other
reasons that they stated in their
prospectus including funding margin
lending operations which of rec reached
a record 358 billion u.s. dollars in
change as the market has surged we have
that chart you can see a 461 percent
over that last year the amount of margin
borrowing in the Chinese market really
driven eighty percent by retail
investors so what are the details of
this IPO seeking as much as four point
eight billion u.s. dollars would be
China's largest domestic IPO since 2010
Chinese brokerage is set to surpass last
year's record of nine point nine billion
dollars raised through share sales
already at seven point six billion
dollars citic securities of course the
largest domestic brokerage by market
value go tae Joon on is largest by
revenue siddik recently announced this
week raising three and a half billion US
dollars and Shen Juan home jaan
securities in a private placement
raising 2.9 billion Wow the biggies
here's the thing though what's the
timing for guate right now is it good
it's a good time in the market right now
we don't know how long this is going to
last right but a lot of market chatter
about the end of the good times right
now we saw this in 2007-2008 the run-up
and then the crash perhaps we're getting
there as well this is a market that is
now dipped in the last couple of days
below 5000 for the first time since june
fourth it soared nearly a hundred fifty
percent already this year but a couple
of pullbacks the last two days down five
point four percent tonya un at northeast
securities in shanghai says brokerages
need money after expanding too fast in
this round of the boom
market added though the market is
nearing a peak Hong how it become
international is even more blunt Angie
everyone is busy looking for the greater
fool it is plain that china is in a
bubble a crash is looming